[Music]
thank you
new figures have emerged at 140 000
children never returned to school after
lockdown journalist and author Harriet
Sargeant has spent the last year
documenting some of Britain's ghost
children and to think tank the center
for social justice has also released a
new report on this issue Harriet's
written about it for the recovery piece
in a magazine this week and she joins me
now along with conservative MP Miriam
Cates who sits on the education Select
Committee
Harriet and Miriam welcome to spectator
TV thank you so much for your time today
um now Harry you've written in a
magazine about the plight of Britain's
ghost children 140
000 of them in the country what's
happened to these children well this is
quite extraordinary because in 2019
there were 60 000 children
um who were out of school more than they
spent time in school now we're you know
how many years are we from finishing
lockdown and yet the numbers are going
up I mean last year when I first looked
at it it was a hundred thousand so this
is a quite extraordinary increase and
from all the the this excellent report
from the center for social justice are
saying that the figures are going to
keep going up because this is a problem
that has not been recognized by
government and which government are
doing nothing about that's incredible
and it falls on a center for social
justice and a journalist like yourself
to bring it to like this this I mean
it's it is quite shocking actually why
do you think the numbers are going up
since the end of lockdown I think that
nobody has realized quite the long-term
damage that has been done to these kids
I mean I interviewed an awful lot of
them and they seem to fall in two parts
there seem to be those that and
generally these are girls but not
necessarily but to just can't go out of
their room they're just crippled by
anxiety they are really distressed
um they they essentially won't go out of
their room
um if they do go to school they manage
like one morning and then they go home
and then there are other The Other
Extreme mainly boys but not not always
Who Won't Go Back Home who are out on
the streets who are into all kinds of
things that they really shouldn't be
into and are angry and are bitter and
feel that they've simply I mean I
interviewed one in stretch from high
streets you said you know he's he was
hoping to get his his results to go to
college and he never got them and his
his dreams are broken and there's young
people like this Young Apprentice all
over the country whose dreams have been
broken and can't get those years back
and Miriam as an MP and the mother of
three you were one of the few
politicians to speak out against school
closures during the lockdown I mean is
this the kind of scenario that you
thought might have happened
well of course these are difficult
decisions and I wouldn't have wanted to
be in any of uh their shoes and uh you
know the Prime Minister former prime
minister has obviously been grilled this
week but I think we have a blind spot in
this country over Children's Welfare and
that wasn't just around the pandemic and
lockdowns we can see that in all many
many areas of our life and politics but
I think
children always should be the first
priority they are our future and we talk
a lot about vulnerable groups and
rightly so but the only truly vulnerable
group in society that we ought to be
protecting at all times is children and
we completely lost sight of them and of
course it's good to protect elderly
people of course it's good to protect
people with health challenges but
actually our top priority our number one
priority should have been children given
what we did know about the disease at
that point which was that it was very
very
um harmless to children and so I think
it's a just indicative of a wider blind
spot that we have in our politics which
is not putting Children First and I
think it was worse than that we actually
used children as a buffer against the
disease
um and to make older people feel safer
which again you know you can understand
politically but I think was the wrong
choice yeah well just on that Harriet
um when it comes to this disparity this
adult's not understanding children well
I was struck by in your piece was how
often kids knew what was going on kids
knew that their friends hadn't come back
to school but they had to go tell the
teachers who then had to take on their
parents so it seemed like the adults
just didn't have a grip on what was
going on whether that's teachers parents
or politicians indeed but the kids knew
what was going on well I mean this very
sad story that you mentioned about one
girl told me that a boy had dropped out
of school and she suddenly saw him
sitting by the side of the road looking
homeless just on on a bit of cardboard
you know very dirty very shabby and she
said he'd always been popular at school
so all the other kids were buying him
food bringing him clothes and finally
someone told the teacher so they got the
boy back into school but he was so far
behind and this is something that seems
to affected a lot of kids where they get
back into school they're so far behind
and he got very angry and he left and
and hasn't really been seen again how
much of it do you think is a poverty
issue as a class issue so like parents
who are you know time poor resource poor
just don't have the time to get their
kids back into school I mean that was
very interesting because there was
definitely the kids the most vulnerable
kids kids in disadvantaged areas on
preschool meals they all have double the
rates of of sort of dropping out to to
their contemporaries
um and certainly there are children who
I mean I know because I befriended um
four boys from a South London gang about
15 years ago and they are at the age of
15 had dropped out I mean they've always
been kids that have dropped out and they
would you know drug dealing and mugging
rather than going to school but look
what's happened to them I mean they in
the last 15 years have been in and out
of prison a path yes
and at Great cost to themselves and and
to ask taxpayers yeah and how are we
going to cope with not you know not 60
000 children but 140 000 and Rising how
are we going to cope with these numbers
of children
if they start going through the criminal
justice system I mean there doesn't seem
to be one uh government institution who
speaks for them I mean there's the
children's commissioner but who and
they're very eloquent but they they
don't have the power yeah who's going to
take responsibility for them well Miriam
let me ask you this question as the
politician in this conversation I mean
where were the adults during the
pandemic you know offstair the
Department of Education the children's
commissioner who I know has been looking
at this but clearly not enough has been
done
well I think the children's commissioner
is excellent and she does a great job of
of shedding light on some of these
issues but I think as Harriet said in
her article she doesn't have any power
um and I think the recommendations that
the csj have made in their reports are
excellent about much more bespoke
um relationships to try and get children
back into school rather than a once it's
one size fits-all finding approach or
something like that so I think there's
some good recommendations but it's a
good question whose responsibility is it
I think again one of the problems that
potentially existed before lockdown but
was made very visible during lockdown is
that as a society we've kind of
privatized family life and we think that
all you need is a nuclear family and all
you need is the household and that if
you just have to retreat into your
household for two years well that's fine
but of course of course it's not fine
you know we exist we are social beings
we need each other not just for
resources and economic purposes but also
for company for learning you know all
these things that we interdepend on each
other for and you cannot just reduce
that to household units it doesn't work
um and again you know who is going to
take responsibility for that I don't
know of course part of it is the
government's responsibility but it's a
whole society responsibility and let's
forget not forget it wasn't only the
government that was shutting schools
down teaching unions were calling for it
some parents were calling for it the
media was certainly calling for it it
actually would have been very difficult
for the government not to do it from a
political point of view so we all share
that responsibilities as Society we were
all obsessed uh with the uh death
figures and the hospital figures
um and wearing masks and how the virus
traveled you know this was a national
Obsession and you know it may be
understandably but very few people in
any Walk of Life were speaking up for
the impact on children
um and I think you know we we are we're
reaping that now not just in educational
loss but in whole culture shifts about
whether education was optional or not
the value that people place uh on
education it's going to take a long time
to roll back so Miriam what do you think
it needs to be done now I mean uh
Harriet writes very well in her piece
about how visitations for early years is
still not back you know some of these
things are still not back to normal as
we've heard about these ghost children
are actually increasing a number not
decreasing so what has to be done now
that we're out of the pandemic and what
is the government doing about it
well again in the report one of the
recommend recommendations is for um an
increased number of attendance officers
that sounds a bit formal but people to
go around building relationships with
families that are struggling and
coaching them back into school into
early years into society and I do think
that's the right approach I don't think
finding everybody or you know change
yeah changing
um a guidance across the board or
anything like that is going to help we
need a bespoke approach so I do I think
that is a good idea but I also think we
we need a mere culpr really we need some
adults somewhere to stand up and say
kids we got this wrong this was not in
your best interests education shouldn't
be optional you you you can't Thrive at
home on your own you need to be back at
school now that might seem a bit
tokenistic but I think when adults get
things wrong we know this as parents
it's important to own that otherwise how
does the how do the children know uh
that a mistake was made and actually
you're taking a new approach so I do
think we need that the government kind
of got in into that space a year ago
Nadine zahari said it was a mistake to
close school which I think was a very
brave thing to do but we need something
much bigger than that to encourage
children to come back
um but you know these issues are very
complex there's not just one group of
children that's struggling yes
deprivation yes special educational
needs girls with anxiety boys who think
that the education system has failed
them anyway and now have seen all the
extracurricular activities canceled to
try and give them more math lessons
there's a lot of questions we can ask
about the education system but I do
think as adults we need a signal that we
got it wrong Harriet yes I mean not a
lot of the children I interviewed were
very angry with their schools and that's
part of the problem because their
schools did nothing and the other thing
that I found so extraordinary was the
variability you know some schools went
out of their way to to to reach their
children see their children even feed
their children I mean as well as teach
them and others did absolutely nothing I
mean I had one boy who was meant to be
at an outstanding School in a sort of
very competitive and he gave up and
started to despair because he nobody was
marking his work he was doing all his
work and then no single teacher could be
bothered to mark his work and he got
very bitter of course and this is true
of many of the kids that I interviewed
so they're not going back into those
school because when it was important
those teachers didn't care for them so
why should they go back and give them a
second chance yes of course I mean do
you think Harriet that ofsted needs to
be overhauled somewhat or just looked at
me if there's outstanding Squad teachers
like what's your education doing I'm
sorry you know why was the Department of
Education saying hello why are some
schools you know busting a gut to teach
children and other schools doing nothing
they were doing nothing I felt quite
children and also within School S I mean
one girl said she had a great history
teacher who was never stopped contacting
her but her English teacher she never
heard of well why was that being allowed
to happen yeah it seems quite quite
extraordinary absolutely Miriam do you
think that looking ahead if there were
to be God forbid another pandemic or
whatever it is we would think a bit more
long-term about this when it comes to
kids
well I hope so and the evidence is
obviously compelling and compounding in
terms of the impact on children of
course it would depend on the nature of
the pandemic I mean I wouldn't be saying
all this if we were talking about
disease which had a 50 mortality rate
for children you know we have to get
this in proportion the reason it was the
wrong policy was because this disease
was so harmless to children and actually
although you know unfortunately lots of
people did die of or with covid
um you know the vast majority of those
that died were elderly and that you know
around the age of life expectancy in in
this country which of course sad but
it's not the same as lots and lots of
young people uh be dying from this virus
so it would depend on the pandemic but I
think we've got so much evidence now
that yes I hope it would be different
but the covert inquiry when the um terms
of reference was first published didn't
even mention children in schooling and
that is a worry you know we need to make
sure that the impact on children is
front and center of of the inquiry so
that we you know we don't forget it and
we make so we use that information in
future really great to hear from you
Maroon kids thank you so much for
joining spectator TV and Harriet
Sargeant too
[Music]
thank you